[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting you boys are talking again
we're gonna be going down the rabbit
hole again but it'll be a different
rabbit hole who knows where the
conversation will take us we don't know
if we're always going to do this in fact
I can promise you that we're not always
going to do this but we're gonna do it
again this week I promise you that you
can't pin us down in any rabbit hole
that's right or in went down rabbits
hole is that what else a rabbit's holes
just say rabbit holes because they talk
about rabbits holes you're talking about
or orifices and we don't do that we I
promise you we're not gonna do that I
don't want to picture that you don't
want to picture that there you can get a
picture that on the internet but again
that's not the kind of thing that I ever
searched for my front yard has all types
of holes in it Gophers and pathways that
have been plumped up from underneath go
first and I believe it is Gophers and I
Google know you know what to do though I
googled what did what what a Gophers go
for if you want him to leave how do you
know I need a lure I didn't get him to
go that's why they're called Gophers not
true but okay and I got like a big screw
top of some sort of it looked like
fertilizer and you sprinkle it over your
yard and it's supposed to repel them go
for repellent go for repellent don't
work don't work because that was that
was six months ago and what that does
according to the Internet is it runs
them into your neighbor's yard and then
they put they throw that stuff out yeah
and then they run back into your yard
and then the the landscape the the
person who mows the grass they just mow
the grass and then they don't what they
do is they don't walk across your lawn
and mush down the gopher humps first so
you know what happens like with that
with the freshly mowed lawn which looks
great I have a little patch of grass my
front that's a dress the guy mows it in
seven minutes
yeah especially but it
we want to take a few minutes to walk
across it and push down the pumps first
because he most straight across and get
short hairs there it gone it's like dirt
all the way down to dirt it just he it's
it's like someone tried to spell in some
sort of go for Sanskrit all over look
like the front edge of my lawn whatever
you thought that maybe very arcane
trying to communicate with you have you
like have you have you just have you
looked at the lawn and just decipher you
know for Sanskrit
no no but just think about it for just
one second just seriously just go with
me here what if they're people what if
you know I've always thought this I've
thought about this a million times what
if all of a sudden I wake up one day and
I'm a gopher not a gopher but I would be
like a squirrel or insect and how do I
communicate to my family and my friends
that yeah I am that animal which is why
you wrote about it way back in that I'm
a thoughtful guy you taught about being
an aunt for my family and friends -
exactly I've actually thought about it
for years so and if the internet didn't
put it - but if those people what if
those are Gophers what if those Gophers
are people are they spelling anything
that's all I'm asking you have you
looked closely enough if you step back
if you've gotten a drone view of your
patch of grass yeah you gotta get a
drone view I can't stand on the roof of
my house I'm not getting a drone I my
experience with drone on the roof I've
been on the roof but I didn't look down
at the go for Sanskrit you gotta do that
next I just looked out I looked out
because I look at the mountain where all
this is leading just so you know I'm
gonna say something that may be
unpopular you the only way to get rid of
Gophers you got to murder them I'm just
saying it I'm just there pest you got to
kill them you know I know it's unpopular
but the Gophers are just I mean I guess
there is some sort of catch and release
but I mean give me a break
they're gonna go they're gonna do the
same thing elsewhere and you may be like
well the Gophers have just as much right
to the land as we do well not really
we're humans we're a lot smarter and
more capable so I mean we've hemmed them
in with a concrete curb and yeah
sidewalk is stuff and I mean if you else
I'm not gonna argue with you if you want
to somehow flush him out like a cartoon
weed like a like a hose and they come
out on top of the the
of water and then you put them in a bag
and take them someplace you want to do
it goes of that trouble that's great
oh yeah but I'm gonna kill him if
they're in my yard I'll put that on vine
oh yeah I mean you get the click signs
coming back I heard about it on I'm
gonna put it on vine um no I'm not gonna
do that if I ate the gopher wood that
redeem this whole conversation I don't
think you have to rustled up to go
Fernan and we ate him I mean you would
be so above reproach if you ate the
Gophers you would be without blame if
you killed 1/8 the Gophers but I think I
think this is almost an insect situation
and like use the pelts for like clothing
for my youngest child and oh go this
humming great I'm gonna go make a pair
of pants
well how many Gophers make all that
tonnage in my front yard I'd say at
least 20 I think go and go for it go for
skin is thick enough to make pants out
of well in LA you make some shorts I
think make a t-shirt maybe you might
make a pair underwear go for go for
thongs oh yeah this is the forego on the
inside of the outside of a go for
thought I think you probably do both why
am I asking you like you like you know
I've got some fur thongs i've guys i've
got some fur on thoughts i've got some
thoughts on fur thongs so what we're
saying is is that you or the step one is
you go on the roof when you make sure
they're not humans that have been
somehow trapped and go over bodies and
they're trying to communicate with you
and you're their only hope because if
they're humans we got ice we can't just
kill them and eat them but if you
determine that they're not you know do
that if that happened I would take a
picture and I put it on reddit you got
to know where these things go if you're
gonna put a hose in there and a Gophers
gonna pop out well that's gonna go on
the new vine you got to get a really
powerful hose but at fireman so but if
but if I take an aerial shot and
something is spelled out by a gopher
like Gophers are humans too that's right
that's the reddit situation which I've
started getting in a reddit well I've
been there for a while I'm looking for
you now cuz I'm on there I'm not an
active poster or comment I got a new
phone
you know I'm not an active phone I'm a
lurker I'm like a gopher of Reddit I was
like I should out of guilt
I should put an app on my phone to do
just experience phone tur tainment which
is not internet tainment which i
consider like youtube videos that's what
we are entertainers you downloaded a
game is that what you know I don't I
looked I was like looking on the App
Store and then reddit was recommended
for some reason because I think they
revamp the app a few months ago they
were touting it I was like you know what
I've heard of this reddit yeah the front
page of the Internet if you will yeah
I'm a will that's what we had the
freakin inventor of Reddit on ear
biscuits alexis ohanian who now is
married to Serena Williams one of the
greatest athletes of all time yeah crazy
they have a baby together
well that guys set right here that guy's
signed this freaking table that we're
sitting at right and I never even went
on his website and I didn't I don't
think I told him that no maybe I did I
did I probably did I don't remember that
conversation I'll have to listen to it
or you can listen to it and tweet a
verse a one degree away from Serena
Williams link about that so now I guess
I can I can strike up conversations with
them because I'm on reddit and I'll do
that sometimes before I'm going to sleep
and I know I'm developing a bad habit
don't yeah don't do that don't be
surfing the interwebs unread before you
go to write no that's a horrible habit
I'm trying to remember the last thing
the thing that strikes me is the tone
with which people comment on reddit it
is such a specific type of conversation
like it's an elevated no matter what you
well it's where I would say it's refined
to be a very specific thing it's it's
it's got to be funny like if you click
on anything like if it's cute if it's
interesting if it's an infinite loop of
something that's perfectly looped that's
my favorite thing on reddit right now
like perfectly looped many videos or
gifs or whatever they happen to be
I'm such an I'm such an out-of-touch
uncle
yeah but if I click on it or like a
weird animal video like the the first
comment that I'm gonna read is gonna be
something that is funny but in a very
specific way like snarky and adding
something to it it's not it's not
anything like and I didn't know this I
mean I'm if you're on reddit I know this
is obvious to you listener and it's just
it's just part of your DNA if you're a
redditor but do you know what I'm
talking about like the snarky smart
[Music]
lots of times cynical but it's like okay
yeah what's posted is funny but what I'm
writing underneath it is also funny and
I know stuff and I'm a di and then I'm
talking about it I'm talking about
things that I know and like but I would
say that while that's true it's also are
trolling people it's it's pertinent more
often than not it contrast it with a
YouTube commenter okay
well a lot of YouTube commenters they
can just comment on something frivolous
or because they're well it's like
because they're seeing something I don't
know I I guess there are videos too but
you don't have anybody talk about the
color the type of shirt that somebody
has on like we've already gotten
comments about your jacket it just
suggests that you know on the video of a
video version of this which is now on
the good mythical morning channel every
Saturday right we've already gotten
comments about your jacket right and I'd
say there are there's a half a duck
there's a dozen or more comments about
your jacket already and then there's
comments about the comments about your
jacket there's thumbs up where did link
get his jacket I love links jacket you
know it's a fine jacket I am a miring
the jacket I'm glad you got the jacket
but you're glad I got the jacket but I
would I would never personally comment
about right jacket on a youtube video
because it seems like well why don't I
just talk about that why don't I comment
on the subject matter of the videos I
think that actually the substantive
parts of the video even a
dumb this video like we make a lot of
dumb videos but but on reddit you're not
gonna get it coming about the jacket
you're gonna get a comment about the
thing that is the post is about and then
people may take issue with certain
things but that's why I said I feel like
it's a slightly elevated conversation
that isn't and there's also not a lot of
self-promotion there's not like a lot of
come and subscribe to my channel or the
coverage I see so many comments now on
YouTube videos like hey you scrolling
through the comments you're beautiful
just the way you are I mean come give me
a frickin break
I mean honestly I oh really cuz you're
like oh thank you no I know I don't care
for that yeah it's it's i i'm not i
don't play here for this dont me wrong
i'm not come you know you know the
person's beautiful who's reading it I'm
not complaining about reddit comments
I'm agreeing with you that you're saying
is beautiful maybe about to go out and
commit a heinous crime you don't know
that they're beautiful I'm not talking
about physical beauty I'm just talking
about you know moral turpitude is that a
word
I serpentine i what I'm saying is that
obviously you can you can tell I'm
ranting a little bit about the nature of
YouTube comments but I'm just saying
that's one of the reasons I'd like to go
so you're saying the reddit I myself
refreshing I don't know if I'm to that
point I'm fascinated by them I am not
annoyed by them but like there's there's
like there was an animal clip because I
think I followed one of these like
animal threads I got to have an animal
thread and not two or three as a gopher
thread it was no it probably was a good
well it was water and then the top said
wait for it and I'm like well wait for
it that's that's how you're gonna mean
this thing and then it's like something
underneath the water and like like a
high angle shot from like a phone
basically FOMA for all like for all I
could care and I'm like whoa what is
this creature it it's kind of its kind
of big it's like it's underneath the
waters like a loch ness monster this
thing oughtn't this things about to
surface it's like it's it's it's
crawling no it's
it's the Loch Ness monster type of thing
yeah and then all of a sudden it emerges
from the water in like a huge flamboyant
way and I realize it's the huge antlers
of a moose and then it's a freaking
entire moose just comes up emerges out
of the water and it just freaked me out
I was like I didn't see that coming I'm
glad I waited for it wait for it wait
for and then I'm like I'm just learning
reddit so I just I'm gonna read the
comments about this like oh you know and
on YouTube what with the comments be wow
a moose
I like that moose is shirt or like that
muses that muses off that muse is
beautiful you're just as beautiful as
that moose oh subscribe to me I've got
moose videos and I don't know enough
about how it works that maybe that's
happening and those are filtered out but
the first comment was was about someone
talking about how it was like a smart
aleck comment about how the number-one
predator of a moose is an orca or color
way killer whale Shamu if you will and
then somebody came in and said well
moves have been known to been to have
been killed by killer whales but the
primary predator of moose are wolves on
land and you know so it's like someone
who knows some stuff is coming in there
and saying stuff and I'm like oh now
they're getting into it and then I'd
like lo and behold 15 minutes later I'm
still reading the comments and now the
conversation is strictly about wolves
you would not more specifically you
would not believe how big a wolf yeah
okay like that's the specific threat
okay so that's a little contradictory to
what I said it's on top not on topic but
that but it's fascinating that something
about a swimming moose literally the
whole thread was impassioned people
talking about encounters they've had
with wolves and
how quote big they are like wolves are
bigger than you what you would not leave
probably all of this and I'm just like
just my thumb just can't keep up with
this conversation and you know what I'm
twenty minutes into a thread about how
big wolves are and how they you know and
it made you a better person just face it
and how it's like well maybe you've seen
a dog that looks like a wolf you know
you don't have to run you don't have to
recreate editor annatto wall because
it's a demo a segue that's what we're
going to do we're not gonna talk about
wolves we it might come back to how big
wolves are but we are going to
essentially do the same thing we're
going to start a conversation and then
we're gonna go into the rabbit hole
wherever the thread might lead but first
we're going to remind you all that just
because you didn't go and see us on the
tour of mythicality doesn't mean you
can't have a what a piece of beasts a
piece of it piece of it there's part of
the piece yeah you can get the the
official limited edition out of print
but still currently for a limited time
in stock rhettandlink - of mythicality
t-shirt and poster that has the same
graphic but also has all of the
locations that we visited own a piece of
rhett and Link Tour history our first
ever tour maybe not our last I'm not I'm
not prepared to say yet
mythical dot stores I don't know for all
your shopping needs well all the
shopping needs that we can meet because
there's lots of things that you might
want to buy that we don't so we need to
come up with a better slogan you know
what I need everything that it takes to
make my breakfast smoothie this morning
okay okay you want to talk about that
now I just I just wanted I want to get
it out of my system I promise I won't
take more than 60 seconds but I just
want you to know I bet you $60 you'll
take more than 60 seconds you can't
speak about something for less than a
minute 30 second oh look who's talking
all of my ingredients I had them and I
made this movie and they all ran out of
this
time like the spinach and the protein
powder and the peanut butter and the
frozen blueberries you know I make it
the same every single morning oh really
I put the recipe in the in the mythical
newsletter way back if you're a
subscriber so you can drink along with
me the breakfast of champions
and it just felt it felt great to know I
was out of things but a 30 suck I could
get it in time to not be out of it in
the morning but to have it all in at the
same time and go in the trash can was
like the best feeling I've had all day
my day started off great for that reason
is that it that's it see okay that's
about 50 seconds okay here is a envelope
or an envelope different a lot of people
who use correct grammar say but I like
you know the whole a Ann thing seems
unnecessary to me
mark ham oh gosh this is mark hamill
posing as a person with a shorter name
mark ham what really happens to all the
things that you lose over your lifetime
what would you do if at the end of your
life someone gave you a box full of all
that stuff all the stuff you lose our
lives now the first part of the question
is many different answers to that but
this this proposition of having a box
with all the things that you've lost
well the first thing that I think about
of course is socks because this is fresh
on the mind fresh on the mind you're
looking for a sock well you may remember
shout out to rhett MC on instagram
that's me that's gross man yeah read it
would burn you that podcast rules are
different men anyway it's a really good
Instagram feed where I happen to post
all my pictures
[Music]
you may recall one of my one of my non
selfie posts you didn't want me to talk
about my smoothie experience so that you
could promote your on Instagram again
was a collection well actually what
happened was what happened was is my
wife had decided that we were going to
she's like we're gonna do sock matching
time every week every week she's
scheduling why am i Oh fun fun fun sock
matching time she said every week we're
gonna get together we're gonna bring our
socks and we're gonna match him up she
just had it in her mind that it would be
a fun family activity if we were to take
all the socks in all four of us were
just descend on this pile of socks like
I'll pack of wolves I told you it would
come back to wolves you wouldn't believe
how big a wolf is a lot bigger than a
dog the legs are super long even if my
three dogs even if you like there's some
breeds of dogs which are much more
closer to that eight related to wolves
but there's still nowhere near that the
size of a war ooh that's not true I'm
quoting a redditor I'm not more closely
related they're just there they're just
they have been less all altered by
artificial selection but they're not
more closely
I guess maybe yeah it's not like they
have a family reunion and they come back
you say we're closer to the wolves
evolutionarily speaking good
some dogs are further down the tree and
others man it's not really a tree if
history drama artificial selection
versus natural selection dogs are the
way dogs are because of artificial
selection that natural selection well
but but in terms of drawing a tree it
doesn't best it it doesn't make a
difference you you lose drawn a tree I
am and I'm saying when man takes over
the process of evolution it's still a
branch on the same tree and it's in the
further a wiener dog is further away
from a wolf it's like when a Siberian
it's like one of those cell phone towers
that looks like a tree yes
anyway she thought it'd be a good idea
for us to descend on this pile and she's
like everybody pair your socks up and
then take them to your room I think
you're just describing laundry did
everybody bring their you try to make it
seem like a party okay halfway through I
realized it wasn't a party
halfway through I realize just nothing
fun about this at all but after I had
paired all my socks and the kids a pair
their socks and my wife I paired her
socks we were left with a collection of
Rogue rogue socks and I arranged them in
a perfect square and took a picture
uploaded it to Rhett MC on Instagram and
it wasn't one of my most liked post ever
or anything but it was pretty artful but
what I said that time and this is this
is a while ago I mean maybe your honor
year ago is that I was like we got to do
something about these socks I was like
first of all I know I don't do really do
the laundry and so I can only I can't
really say too much but I was like it
can't be this hard to keep up with the
socks it's like every time I even begin
to broach that a little bit my wife just
gets very agitated mm-hmm
and so I can't really go there but I was
like we gotta get rid of these rogue
socks it's like we got to get them out
of the mix cuz she's like well but they
turn up
she's like the socks eventually turn up
and then you can make the pairs right
right I'm like if they don't turn up
after two or three cycles anyway they're
gone lost until the end of your life so
we came up with a have in the box right
so we came up with the idea to start
over sock ground zero and actually last
night last night well the other night I
went on Amazon and and me and the boys
picked out socks I mean me and lock boys
let's have my version of a sock party
which is just buying a bunch of new
socks indiscriminately no no no no it
was so the new system is I'm intrigued
by this all the socks are the same my
socks and lock socks are the same same
exact same exact socks oh he's a man now
so you're a boy now yeah either way
young at heart
either way we share socks yeah
so there's none of this like Locke Sox
Red Sox Shepherds smaller he gets his
own suck lock and I decided I want well
I'll show you I see where you're going
with this as you are you you're pulling
up a sock no okay
not a sponsor Dickies it's actually a
work sock but you know what I'm working
all the time and it's it's just a thick
black sock with a wide array bottom and
then he says Diddy's right there on the
toe it's kind of hard to see that part
believe it and how is that a crew sock
we're talking about yeah half-caf crew
yeah
crew sock and it's a it's an affordable
sock that was that was goal number one
and I go I like black socks okay because
basically what you're saying is between
two people in your house you're you know
you've bought a whole bunch of socks and
then they all go together it's just you
know you just find two and they
automatically go together there's no
circular and Shepherd got grey socks so
they're different and yeah Jesse just
kept her socks cuz leave her totally
different so so then last night socks is
like a form of expression all the socks
came in a box a socks box and I got all
my socks and I was like this is gonna be
incredible now this is a freaking sock
party let's take these socks out let's
put them in our drawers and I mean not
our pants but you know the drawers in
let's put let's throw all the other
socks away or let's give the socks to
Goodwill whatever and so then you giving
you giving one no no no no one socks
trash old pairs of socks that don't fit
the new system which is all my socks are
the same the same as locks and Shepherd
socks were all the same get thrown out
get give giving away now yes but but she
wouldn't go for this what speaking of
Gophers I knew we come back to Gophers
because you would not believe she a big
ago what she solved these socks and
shoes Nike black socks and she was like
we can just keep these I was like but
they're not Nicky's they're paired
together they're nice they
in the system because now all of a
sudden there's gonna be a rogue Nike
sock swimming in the Dickies I don't
think may she might have tuned out at
some point during your party yeah so
this is I didn't succeed oh it's not all
Dickies know how you're sneaking socks
and taking about it am I draw my keys
have to go
I'm with I I'm a little upset about the
I'll throw my way later I miss you won't
even know she won't even know the sock
phantom can come so that that's how I've
solved this problem in my house I got a
few follow-up questions are you telling
me you've committed to a crew SOT link
sock because it what about a no-show
because I think that's pretty important
okay if it was me I would have said you
know what right now at this juncture of
my life even at this point in in my look
I'll just show you here look at that
black sock black pants hairy ankle Lee
white strip in the middle is my flesh
because if I'm wearing a shoe you can't
tell that I'm wearing a sock he's a
no-show suck well that's familiar that's
it and and it's not quite that's not a
super no-show a super no show I'm not a
super no-show it's just it's well given
my shoes it's a no-show given the
particular pair of shoes that Jelena
yeah I'm not wearing like a loafer or
penny loafer
now you but so that's that's what I
would choose and that's what I'm gonna
choose cuz I'm gonna do this okay well I
don't solve do this mythical beast I
don't want to throw a wrench into your
sock party but let me just say mmm I did
also by crew socks no I mean I bought no
show white athletic socks white for the
gym time that's risky cuz even that
little peeking of white coming out is
just cheap you should have gotten black
for those but you didn't wanna you
didn't want to mix it up with your with
your long lease only exactly exactly
link yeah do you saw where I was going
with this they were white even though I
would prefer them to be black they were
white so that they had to be so the sock
party will be easy
now let me also say I have an extreme
no-show sock from previous decisions
right that looks like a ballerina it's
basically this little gray thing that
they sell at Urban Outfitters you know
where if you it's basically you know
it's not you don't want the show socks
the show you don't want people to know
that you even think about so that's
called a no-no sock right it's like yeah
and it barely fits around I mean it's
the type of embarrassing to be caught
with these socks on yeah nothing else if
you if somebody sees you walking around
and just those socks and no shoes it
just drains them any masculinity that
you may have have right now you have to
have a backstory for those you have to
have a story my story is if I'm ever
caught in those I just say it they're
therapeutic and then I just leave it at
that because people don't like to ask
medical question toe circulation he's
got a condition I don't want to ask
about it like like TSA TSA gives you
lucky like therapeutic so he's gonna
leave them on I mean I signed up for pre
check just to avoid having to say
anything about therapeutic side right
because you want to learn sometimes
anyway I kept those because those are so
distinct and I have a two pairs of shoes
you know these shoes those little
they're actually a Timberland shoe that
those little gray shoes that I have that
are the almost cloth the simplest shoes
yeah yeah got like earth something from
Timberland and I love those shoes I got
a couple of pairs and you have to wear
knows if you wear socks with those shoes
dorky time yeah just like clocking in
the dark you down so check it back in
sir
I'm sorry that you missed me for a few
hours when I was wearing no-show socks
but I'm back in [ __ ] town but where's
it where's my assignment sir but the
problem is is that my my feed the
lemonade concession stand my feet Arnold
Palmer's three for a dollar sweat like
you wouldn't believe
you know I don't sweat under my arms I
sweat from me I swept from the ends I
swept from
the hands and the feet extremities yeah
I've been about the height in the
centrifugal force right so there's a lot
of there's a lot of leverage you swing
the sweat out of your extremity right
and so anyway I kept those they're easy
to keep up with and then I kept my dress
socks but they're they're polluting the
drawer so I took all the dress size
because I never wear dress socks unless
we do something when you have the wear
dress socks and so I took the dress
socks I put them in a shoe box put it in
the top of the closet for that special
time when you need to dress a lot of
dress size and I never will buy that's
the system so far you might as well burn
that box or give it to the goodwill
you'll never access that box I don't
believe you I think I will ah I'm only
one day in though I started wearing
dressy or sucks because I would um we
you know I have dress socks could I get
a new pair every time we would go on
Fallon because people you know you throw
your leg up and you expose the sock and
new people will comment on we got to do
the duck again it's a double leg thing
is that you to come anything you guys
want to we post Hey look we were on The
Tonight Show and you're like let me
comment about your socks yeah we feed
right into we feed right is you wear
Dickies next time and and talk about it
not get paid
yeah hopefully there will be a next time
you know we had that falling out with
Jimmy last time yeah I know you said
that thing about hanging out from that
no Jimmy you know we're joking you and
we know you're listening right that's
the lease how big a wolf is Goku Gophers
are people too I mean we got a couple of
things we get her on t-shirts already
Gophers maybe people to him Gophers are
people too
yeah that's probably better shirt right
it is an aerial view the dirt design
it's a front yard
it's about your grass yeah it's my patch
of grass and it's petting and then the
Gophers have done it so anyway when I
open my sock drawer and I see those
dress socks it's kind of like a timeline
of like pleasant memories that I've had
with Jimmy Fallon
I honestly yeah yeah and I'm kind of a
touch of those and then Christie got me
a pair of camouflage socks that have
little wiener dogs on them that looked
like Jade and I'm pretty awesome I
called those my favorite socks
no no but you also got some from a from
a mythical beasts yep and then a
mythical beast on tour in the
meet-and-greet line gave me and you -
you got a peach got a pair of socks with
an actual printed picture of our dogs on
them so I have Jade's face on my on my
socks yeah the people who follow the red
MC Instagram account know about my
Barber's and those those socks are
important to me - Christy was mad by the
way when I brought those home cuz she
said I was gonna get you some of those
for your Christmas stocking
she had a sock party planned she yeah
she had to cancel it
but even so I've got all these special
dress socks up there but then I keep
looking for black in the top drawer the
one closest to my face is it all socks
in there that you got difference how do
you how you separate this dress from the
regular size there's an organizer on the
left side and it's got like you have a
dress you have an organizer in the
drawer in the drawer yeah
and in that zone though there's like a
lighter and there's like a candle or two
this is my bedroom you know you gotta
have you have a candle and sock drawer
it's a candle lighter slash sock drawer
okay there's a couple of there's a
couple of receipts there's a receipt
area in there your socks don't smell
like candles what if they do bonus now
if your candle smell like socks didn't
you got a prob so I'm running over your
system here and I'm in but I'm compelled
because every time I open the drawer I
see all these socks that are special to
me but I'm always looking for the black
like little socks like the ones I just
showed you and you're like default so
yeah and they're hardly ever they're
right in like a while back I bought a
whole slew of them and I was like
they'll all be the same when I can put
them together but then Lincoln socks he
I think all of my stocks have slowly
migrated either to like the the upside
down or they're in Lincoln's drawers but
somebody else who's organizing the Sox
thinks that they're all his you have to
so you're really honest or what if your
wife is is the one who handles that you
just have to say this is my sock I pair
a lot of socks Lincoln pairs a lot of
socks too but I think you're right it I
got to combine forces with my with my
oldest son
yeah he's foots big enough now yeah he's
got a daddy foot now you've got a wide
foot so I'm really open to this but I
don't know what to do with all my
special socks usually cut bait I just
think that I talk about what we're gonna
do with our sock I don't know I think we
can talk about it for a long time this
sucks
the specialty is a good system specialty
socks I thought about this as I put the
Barbara socks into the shoe box which
you say will never see the light of day
yeah I thought to myself it is possible
that I will forget about this box of
special socks and you know what I'm okay
with that
because here's altima Lee what I'm doing
here
I am eventually going to wear the same
thing every day and I'm starting with
the song we've talked about this and
there's absolutely no doubt in my mind
that wearing exactly the same thing
every day is the preferred way to dress
I mean there is an absolutely you cannot
talk me out of this Steve Jobs was a
smart man very very creative guy but you
know what it's a decision he didn't
wanted to lose not man - and I I haven't
read or talked to him about that
decision but a lot of people who do that
a lot of people who make a lot of
decisions do that because they wanted to
they don't want to start their day with
a lame decision like what am I gonna
wear here's a here's a caveat though I
was told by someone who had personal
interactions with Steve Jobs recently
that he would walk around work with
turtleneck tennis shoes and cutoff jean
shorts ooh
frequently had you ever heard this about
Steve Jobs until you got to cutoff jeans
I was in uniform the exact same uniform
except the cutoff shorts formed and like
yes may not I have short not jean shorts
but like the jeans that you wouldn't
normally see him leader jeans a now
typically had on cut with scissors
simple efficient just like no a computer
just like everything that I wear the
same thing every day the only problem is
sometimes I wish I was wearing shorts
solution I'm gonna cut the jeans and he
did that it is the most immediate
solution yeah
when when the only thing you're thinking
about is efficiency the first thing you
do is you just cut the jeans you don't
get another type of clothing I stand by
it I think it's a great idea I'm nervous
I mean what our comments would just go
away oh no no no we can't no engage yeah
I'd have to here's the thing I'd have to
use I'd have to dress up like a dressing
up to be a character to do our show but
then in my everyday life I would be
wearing the same thing so I'm not sure
we do keep this is a fun topic of ours
because we do go back to it a lot I'll
add a data point from me which is I
don't know how I acquired some like
legitimate sweatpants and I think this
is what you thought about you at Altima
wear sweatpants on unlike a podcast that
we did probably and I went a whole day
just wearing the sweatpants and I
actually went out in public with him on
and everything I'm like you know I've
seen pictures of Kanye coming out of
this going in and out of the studio and
people talk on yay is smiling 20:18 is
gonna be amazing and he's wearing just
sweatpants yeah what I'm like man Kanye
can do it he's a fashion icon he's in
everything icon to me what kind of
sweatpants just think of the most normal
sweatpants like nothing fashionable at
all about them the bottom has just has
that stringy thing like it doesn't have
like the fancier cuff like none of that
I don't want to get us off topic keeps
going to talk about cunning sweats but I
I really admire what you've done with
your socks well I appreciate it
no but let's get back to mark hams
question if all those all the socks that
don't have pairs what are they if they
came back at the end of your life that's
no no but grozny wait but what do you
think do you think that okay and I'm
talking like we're talking I'm 30 to 40
socks easy in a lifetime no right now
yeah right now are all the other socks
in my house in different places what
percentage of the socks are in my house
and where are they in my house and if I
had to if somebody came to me and said
we're gonna burn your house down if you
don't find every one of these socks in
the next 24 hours what methods would I
employ to find them and where would they
be you you might as well be asking me to
cure cancer right now I mean it's like
that is freaking it's not fair man it's
not a fair question I'm like I got I
guess like what's the key to world peace
like no no but what where is that where
are the socks no no there is no ant
there's no answer yeah yeah but there
are answers okay I'm gonna try let's
think of some possibilities first of all
87% of the time if if you look at anyone
unpick match sock eighty percent
certainty that that other site is in the
house like if there was a tracker on it
you would you it would be you could even
hear it see I go above 95% 95% 95% of
all socks are still in the house and
then of that 95 percent my theory is
that 50% of those are in the laundry
room probably behind the one the washing
machine at least in my house they're
under the doís Shing machine they're
behind the washing machine like I'd say
there's yeah I'm so in my case we're
talking 15 to 20 individual socks
probably in the laundry room and like
when they went whenever they there that
changed though did the washer well
they're at future I think this and it's
an equal distribution like if you if you
look at the if you look at the life
cycle of a sock at every place where
there's a trance
okay then there's a there's a big chance
that there's gonna be a separation
there's gonna be like a Todd and copper
situation you know they're gonna one of
them's gonna grow up have one is gonna
have to go away for the summer he's
gonna come back and the other was gonna
be growing up and they can't be friends
anymore who's Todd and copper you know
Fox in the hound oh you take off your
socks you throw them in the dirty
clothes but one of them misses the
hamper it's behind the hamper and then
you pick up the hamper and then it
scoots under the mat or it's you know it
they've separated they are at they're in
different ecosystems this Jeff it's like
Jake get your socks uh no Barbara is
often seen with a sauce just walking
around with a sock in her man ha ha I
mean there she goes I mean so she is
she's the x-factor man oh yeah a dog is
it a dog that likes to put socks on her
mouth because then when X Factor yeah oh
yeah that I mean you that's crazy when
you cuz even without the dog then you
take the hamper if they're both in the
hamper and you dump it out before you're
gonna put it in you maybe you you pull
it out of the hamper and you're throwing
everything or trying to sort stuff to go
into the washing machine and then you
know things are getting separated there
you pull stuff out of the washing
machine and you're immediately just
gonna throw it in that dryer and you're
grabbing the biggest hunks of clothes
you can in order to like only do it in
three goes and what's gonna fall to the
ground one of the socks and then it's
gonna get pushed under it's gonna you
know depending on if you're a top load
or a front load it's like I've thought
about all this and it's just folly
you've done a good thing you sidestepped
all of it you know there's gonna be an
there's a sock attrition rate you know
you're constantly it's like skin cells
they're just dying right and you know
what you don't need to stop and think
about saving them you gotta move forward
just gotta live with the skin you got
live in the skin you're in not the skin
that's falling off now were you a part
of this conversation
it was either a show or a podcast or I
don't know maybe we talked about it I
don't know if I was there
good morning but I was probably there
there there is a guy who insists on he
believes that there's a right sock and a
left sock he believes that there was a
sock for your right foot and it's like
for your left foot now he understands
that socks are not made for right feet
in life you mean there are some
specialty socks that are made obviously
toe socks i-i've never heard contributed
or been a part of okay or glanced at
this conference so this is a fact there
is a dude I think was probably on one of
these like ridiculous reality shows
where it was like something that couple
was arguing over a brother or something
you know like I'm talking like a like a
dr. Phil type of thing you know I was
like this Mayan Springer insist on
wearing his socks on his left in his
right foot his wife wants to kill him
because of it on the next dr. Phil but
the here's what he did he he banana he
believed that once he wore a sock it
became that it stretched to get oriented
it oriented itself as a right foot or
left foot he swore up and down that he
could put on or left foot for the right
foot and he would know so he made his
wife label his socks right and left and
I think he went as far so you had to
match don't bring your wife into this
labor your own dang son had to match the
pair but then he didn't had to be the
right in the left and so I mean this was
it's absolutely nuts but so you haven't
heard of that before
but that but that guy when he loses see
I've gone completely to the opposite end
of the spectrum where I'm not even it's
not I'm not I'm just mixing I'm not just
mixing left and right I was already
doing that I'm not just mixing pairs of
socks now I'm mixing whoo the socks are
for because I'm sharing them amongst the
family right I mean in as soon as
Shepherds foot is big enough we're all
gonna be wearing the same socks and if I
can get my wife to just wear my socks
too we could
I'll be wearing the same sucks she is
three feet shorter than you how much
shorter is her foot than yours her SOT
your sock it's significant your know so
shot I can't say it would go all the way
to her to or me but do you know what it
would make your life simpler yeah but
okay but what what about other things
because they have Jessie wearing
stockings all of a sudden knowledge what
else have you lost of significance in
the past let's say year serious really
digging deep for this one I'm trying to
think of something else that I've lost
you lose things all the time but then I
find them usually like I lose things
that are really important to me and so
everything has to stop and I have to
find it right then like T's wallet ID
credit card middle child you know it's
like things that okay this is serious
III really can't think of anything else
that I've lost it will be in that box at
the end of my life do you I mean do you
have something else that you've lost now
yeah so interestingly I don't lose
wallet keys I mean I'm not saying I
don't misplace it from time to time and
to and I do now and I do have the tile
because the tile was a sponsor so I've
got the tile on my keys in my wallet but
my phone my keys in my wallet 99 days
out of a hundred when I'm leaving I just
I know where they're at
even if and I don't even leave them in
the same place it's just there's a
couple of places that I might leave
things I don't really lose those kind of
listeners and what have you lost
what are you looking I lose sunglasses
now you don't lose your sunglasses you
have prescription sunglasses they're
super expensive and you wear them
religiously I have like cheap multiple
pairs of cheap you know less than $20
sunglasses and but that I did have a
pair of those Ray Bans that folded up
into a square which was unnecessary I
will say who needs it to be a square
really but I lost those you know why
because they fold it up yeah where's
half the size they need to whenever you
take them off they need to expand to the
size of like a unfurled flag that's what
they really have needed to be I it's
just anything that's not a part of my
routine is susceptible to being lost but
I can't think of anything I did you know
well I lost my phone last year first
ever phone I've never had a phone break
and I've never lost a phone and you know
10 years of or however many years it's
been it's longer than that of cellphone
use but you know the story of I think I
told it on the podcast of having the
phone fall out of my pocket while skiing
it's Sundance and then but I didn't I
technically didn't lose it because I
could locate it with Find My iPhone on
like for the next three weeks because it
was so cold the matter separated from it
but you didn't lose it is that what
you're saying yeah but I lost it because
I never got it I just don't I just don't
know why even if even if you were prone
to lose things that were important to
you
like if if they showed up when you on
your deathbed in a box that would just
be very frustrating I know be horrible
no no I actually think this is a
beautiful proposition really because I
think it's like I think if me man I even
I I finally gave up on that it's like
well you know and then you know the
boxers come when you're dying it's like
man I can't find this and I know it's
gonna show up that thumb its nose at me
when I'm when I'm dying well I wasn't
picturing it like that like it was that
everyone knows that there's this box
that's brought to you I would what I was
saying is that if I was about to die and
somebody was like Rhett we have this box
this you know magical box because this
box really can't exist but it's
everything that you ever lost
mostly socks but think through those and
you'll get to something important I
think that it would be like he
a way to like it would be like a
interesting antique catalogue of my life
because I'd be like oh yeah I member
that thing from this point I think it
would be amazing I would love that
it I mean you be that I didn't even know
I lost that well I just forgot thing I
forgot to think about it for a while
well you know let me I do remember
something that I lost and then I found
and I'm gonna I'm gonna run it through
the grid of how I felt and see if maybe
you're right about this box even if it
is the end of your life and you're dying
I know what you're gonna talk about
right now um I was because I'm actually
driving the FJ this week because the
car's in the shop Christie's got a draw
her car's in the shop got to drive my
car so then I'm driving the FJ because
you don't drive it you don't need it
every day so I've been driving that
thing you know remind me that last time
I was driving that thing for a long time
it wouldn't the the gear stick wouldn't
work right and then I gave it back to
you and you're like gear shift won't
work and eventually you got upset
because it would go into Drive and we're
going to park but it wouldn't go into
like the lower drive gears right like it
wouldn't going to like drive 3 2 or 1
like if you wanted to downshift manually
it was very difficult which I which by
the way I do a lot like driving in the
hills and stuff of course I like down
ship I like use the transmission to slow
down not the brakes that is a good but
in a car talk that's a good thing well
everyone should be doing that you could
ruin your brakes in one downhill descent
yeah everybody should be less redundant
but you couldn't for some reason you
couldn't do that the gear shift thing
was broken and but I didn't fix it it's
your responsibility now Thanks so then
you took it in and I mean you can tell
the story right they came back to you
and and told you what was wrong with it
you remember oh you have it oh you don't
yes oh this isn't the story you thought
I was gonna tell us no no no okay no I
remember now remember what it was well
you came up to me and you put something
in my hand
and it was you're like this is yours
isn't it and I'm like yeah that's my
that's my Leatherman tool it's a it's a
knife with all this it's like a Swiss
Army knife but it's you know it's bigger
yeah and and I was like dang I bet I
lost that and you're like well the
mechanic found it inside of the
transmission of the FJ and it had it had
lodged down in there didn't make it all
the way to the transmission but it was
to the gearshift it was in the housing
and it literally wouldn't let the
gearshift go and I was like that's where
that thing went I remember putting it
down next to the gearshift in it well
and it's amazing cuz you know there's
like this and I felt very small like
little slit that like the bleeder shift
hand it travels through yeah but there's
like a little there's like a leather
thing that goes around the hole and like
goes up and it it was a loop on the
gears it was a little bit loose and it
it snuck under there and like gone and
into the upside down but when I got that
thing back I'm like man this is great
because I put this in the the upper cup
holder of my car so that then it's a
makeshift platform to then set my phone
on perfectly so I kind of look at use my
phone as a GPS and with that it's been
gone for the past month I can't see the
bottom half of my GPS in the holder and
I was really bummed out about that
because of course I'm not allowed to use
the actual knife part of my knife I just
use it as a platform for for my phone so
I was pretty pumped to get that thing
back I'm sorry that it cost you some
money to fix your he gear shift but
totally worth it from my perspective
so in which I think goes but I wasn't
dying if I was dying I was like man I'd
rather not know that this thing was gone
that whole time you wouldn't even
remember but yeah you probably never
remember at that point when you were
dying what did you think I was gonna say
that I lost all that you're gonna talk
about the blood oath oh yeah that oh
that's the perfect thing so I you know
the story we did a blood oath in middle
school saying that we were gonna grow up
together and create things together it
happens it worked
the blood oath worked we wrote a
contract on on a piece of paper two
different pieces of paper and we said we
will something to the effect of we will
create something together we're gonna
like work together to create something
and it was very nebulous because we
didn't know what that would be here
whatever we cut our palms with rocks
sharp rocks and then we smeared our
blood on the tube we did actually I
don't know if we actually shook hands we
did I don't think it was more about
taking blood and putting on a Saturday
was signing it and like either was my
blood in your blood on each piece of
paper and we each had a copy and you
immediately lost you know I lost my mean
I probably lost mine after I put mine in
my desk with a bunch of other stuff but
you kept yours in your wallet until what
age college no high school in high
school I was definitely 16 because I was
driving and I was like I remember the
last play
I lost my wallet it was at that party at
Trent Hamilton's house when his parents
went out of town oh I remember that
night and then I had lost my wallet
there and then when I eventually found
my wallet it wasn't in there and or like
it's very fuzzy but I remember that I
recovered the wallet but the thing
wasn't in it or I realized that at some
point it was no longer in it and that I
had lost it the oath I'd love to have
that back yeah see you'd love to have
that and you'd love to have it on your
deathbed it would be that would be a
good moment to say wow that's like it's
like a time capsule moment yeah it's
ironic that something so important to
you you could still lose so then when
you you know even when you're dying you
could be glad to see it well the first
part of the question you know what
happens to all that stuff I think that
your leatherman story illustrates this
is that there's a perfectly logical
explanation for everything that you've
ever lost right so it isn't like
anything that you've ever lost was like
a leprechaun took it from you like
that's that's not the kind of thing that
happens right it's it there's a sort of
light
I can't of course that's where the thing
is of course that's where the sock is of
course that's where the oath is mmm
there is that one crevice that you just
haven't creased but it's amazing how
often even though it's uh it's it's
obvious where these things end up most
likely how often it still happens it's
just but I think you I think the
explanation to the first part of your
question mark would just be kind of like
oh yeah that's what happened to it
boring you know what I mean
slip through the frickin crack in the
gear shift
you remember buddy boring a year ago
there was that I think this is on
Twitter there was the the person who
found her
elderly mother's wedding ring like
diamond ring was lost and like the
backyard and then it they were pulling
up carrots in the garden and they pulled
up a carrot it had a freaking ring and
it had her freaking it did it had grown
through the wedding ring and you could
like see that it was the carrot was
bigger on either side of the wedding
ring it was like you know if if it just
like if a tree grows around a barbed
wire fence that's what it looked like
yeah I mean many years later I don't
think it was it was much more than a
perfectly proves the point
the losing was unspectacular the losing
was fell off while gardening went into
the grass but the finding was
spectacular plucking a carrot out of the
ground and that's like that's kind of
what the box at the end of your life
represents but but yeah and an to take
the analogy further that carrot had to
die for her to get that ring back mmm so
you think they ate it no you can't eat
the carrot to get to the ring
definitely boiled it that's how they
prepared it picked a better way but
ultimately ultimately the the goal
should be
get to a place where it doesn't matter
if you lose things where you're not
attached to any material object to the
extent where you care what happens to it
well it's interesting that the ultimate
goal on a philosophical level unlike a
unlike a Wellness level yeah to
recognize that okay even okay let's take
our wedding rings writing right now okay
there's sentimental value attached to
our wedding rings there is significantly
more sentimental value attached to your
wedding ring not because your marriage
has more sentimental than mine but
because I had this ring made yeah for me
and and and and for my marriage so it's
as old as my marriage right in this form
I'm sure that the elements in it are
much older but your ring but mine is my
grandfather my Papa Clyde who passed
away in 1998
this is his wedding ring when he married
my nanny who I guess two podcasts ago I
told you about visiting her you just
said to puck to podcast Co who Tupac was
very good friends with us like what was
this going to park dedicated many of our
raps to my my nanny in my my my papa
Clyde so this is Clyde's wedding ring
and then when he passed away Chrissy and
I had just started dating and that was
one of the first time she met my family
was coming to the funeral like meeting
like I don't know it might have been the
first time she met nanny
I don't know ring is incredibly valuable
yeah it's his and his wedding ring the
way that now it's my only way that you
you fidget with your ring a lot more
than I do
you take your freaking ring off all the
time yeah I've seen you drop it in weird
places yeah I drop it I've draw a drop
it in meetings on a weekly basis I could
it could it could stroll down a sewer
grate at any moment but let's explore
for a moment
fine to me what is it like materially
speaking is your ring more valuable you
saw so I'm saying
so like the it's the value of your ring
is in obviously it's in the intrinsic
value of the metals or whatever but the
value that you've attached to it that
gives it more valuable value than mine
the sentimental value is a value that
exists in your mind it's just a value
that exists in your mind right so I'm
not saying that it's not significant I'm
not trying to downplay it right I I
really want to I don't really want to
explore this because yeah yeah yeah what
is that value made of like legitimately
is it not true that that value is just
very simply a neural pathway in your
mind that is connected to your
grandfather
and so basically there's a certain
collection of neurons in your brain that
fire in a certain pattern I don't know
how the brain works and it's all the
value that you attach to this physical
object that you wear around your one
specific finger that has been chosen for
by our culture to signify that you're
married you've attached extra value to
that because of whose it was whose other
finger it was on and I'm not saying
that's a bad thing I'm just saying that
is it ultimately a good thing that we
have the capacity to it to attach that
much value to it and what what does that
even mean what is that even real value
well and let me tell you another quick
story tell me in order to explore this
further because it has a it has a twist
ending which will I think bring up a
related question maybe answer you a
question night before last
Christy relayed what she had done at
what had happened she said she was
cleaning out drawers in the in the
dining room which is something that
could be is a
both of ours like to clean out drawers
and she said I found the the handwritten
log from last year when Lily was just
out of her back surgery and she was
recovering and we had to log all of the
medication she was taking to take it at
the proper times and also how much food
she was eating because she had she had
to gain weight and she had complications
associated with the surgery that meant
that she had to you know we had to get
more calories in her for reasons that
aren't I don't need to go into but
anyway so this basically one sheet of
paper was an artifact from that moment
in Lily's life when you know it was a
big test for her so Lily was at school
Christy said I went into a room and I
put it on her bed and I put a note on it
and said just in case you've forgotten
how strong you are because she was
talking about how she's having some
challenges at school whatever just look
at this and then it was that that she
attached the note to that lock and then
Christy says and so Lily got home and
you know it was it meant a lot to her to
get that and it was very sweet and she
said so of course I think what I'm gonna
do and this is Christy talking of course
I think what I'm gonna do now is I'm
just gonna take a picture of the log and
it throw it away and and I was like I
was shocked that she said that but it's
it's interesting right I think she's on
the right track she's transferring it to
the cloud now if you could transfer that
to a locket and wear it around your neck
maybe that's I'm gonna make that there's
two different things going on here it's
like the the wedding band is something
that's on your person like this is like
when I get naked I said I'm still
wearing this good you know which yes
good for like a number of reasons
because it's a wedding banner but you
know if it were if she was gonna like
burn
that that that thing and then put the
ashes and lock it and carry it around
around her neck is a symbol of her own
inner strength that could be meaningful
but just having a sheet of paper that
you're gonna shove in a drawer and then
maybe lose or you know it's gonna like
deteriorate or something you might as
well digitize it so in the event of a
fire you're not running trying to find
it so I think that's the threshold if
you can't carry it on your person even
when you're naked I think then you
should move it to the cloud like I can
carry it I can carry a note well naked I
mean I'm pretty sure I could do that
without the use of your hands I think
that's I think find a place because I
are we closer than answering your
question which was yeah yeah you you're
all over it right because basically what
Christie is doing when she says that
she's going to take a picture of this as
she's saying that the thing that is
valuable is the particular arrangement
of that information right which can be
captured digitally and at some point
could even be recreated physically or
like a 3d printer all the pictures that
we scan to put in our book now that
they're a in our book and then be I
can't I did to me there's a box of
artifacts in our office we can lose it
because it's been rket barnett you could
just soon as burn but you're actually
you're talking about two very very
interesting things right which there's
there's a there's another podcast in
this whole this whole thing but we can't
talk about it forever but the first
thing you're talking about is just what
is it that we're attaching the value to
like because it's and then the second
part is what is attached to value
because it kind of goes back to this the
the conversation that we had you know
shout out to the red MC Twitter I'd I
use Dana I don't shout out to the
Twitter very much I mean I really don't
so i mean you gotta give me a chance i
tweeted i told you about that the
restaurant experience i had dialogue
restaurant in in los angeles
and it was this it was a gift for my
in-laws to go to this incredible
restaurant that was like a 12-course
meal and the chef was 12 cornmeal
absolutely amazing and I told you about
the story the story associated with
every dish right yeah and the fact that
he had certain albums playing while you
were eating in this restaurant and he
was any and he said I'm specifically
playing albums that really makes sense
as an album in fact some of these albums
like he referenced one of the roots
albums he was like this is actually not
that great of an album if he listened to
it on shuffle because it's actually the
arrangement of the songs and the story
that they tell in the and the order that
they tell him that it was where the
beauty in the album is and so he said
that's specifically the way that I've
arranged this meal so I told you the
fascinating thing about this is that in
every course in the meal
there was a piece there was an
ingredient from the previous course that
was looking back to the past and there
was an ingredient from the future course
the next course that was looking to the
future it was linked and operate
everything was linked together and then
there was even things on top of that
like this this particular one is
inspired by this painting and there's
the painting and the painting was up in
the restaurant he would point to it and
we had the great we were at the bar we
could see him make these dishes and one
of the most incredible meal experiences
of my life now if you just isolated one
of those dishes and just brought it out
and ate it I'd be like this is an
incredible meal but I you know a
chick-fil-a chicken sandwich is an
incredible meal
I mean the flavor combination in a
chick-fil-a chicken chicken sandwich it
doesn't get much better than that a
piece of pizza from a fine pizza
establishment it doesn't get much better
than that in terms of flavor in your
mouth right
but the story connected with a piece of
pizza is that well it's from this
restaurant they make it out but the
story connected to any particular course
in this meal that I was having the
value-add
from my brain to the meal experience
that I was having that then impacted the
physical sensation that was actually
taking place in my mouth which was then
sending more signals back to my brain
which enhanced the whole experience
that's that's humanity that's that's how
we interact with life we're constantly
attaching value to just arrangements of
atoms right and I'm not saying that
there is ones and zeroes I mean first of
all we can't help it we're programmed to
do this right our bodies are designed to
to work in a particular environment an
environment that we're actually not in
right now an environment that we used to
be in you know with Stone Age hardware
running modern day software and we can't
help but attach value to things because
there's an adaptive advantage to
attaching value to things things that
are significant to us but I think one of
our challenges is not to say ok you
should think that your ring is you
should just take a picture your ring and
flush it down the toilet I'm not saying
that you should do that but wouldn't it
be a healthier place mentally and
emotionally if you could do that without
any real regret and you may say that's a
lie that's not a life worth living and I
do it but you'll never get to that point
because you're a human you can't just
deny your humanity but what steps can we
take where and your ring is a bad
example because that ring is not a vice
it's it's a beautiful memory of your
grandfather and a beautiful symbol of
your love for your wife and so there's a
lot of there is it symbolizes things
that have meaning way beyond the metal
right but we attach value and
significance to I'll think to a lot of
things that don't matter and actually
don't symbolize things that have any
real and you know I I think I think
you're just you're construing
possessions with in like knickknacks
with keepsakes for this thing I think
but the thing that makes that value is
the story that you've attached to it
yeah but it was there man it was this
like you know if if if
if I reached under this table and pull
out Abraham Lincoln's top hat like that
would be okay wrong long I would be like
you know what I just it would mean so
much yeah it would mean so much to me if
you had Abraham Lincoln's top bet I
would think it was super cool I'm just
saying that whereas it can be a super
cool thing there's probably a lot of
like the actual like I mean they keep
the Constitution under underlay suck it
down in a vault every night and then
they pick it up in the elevator so
people can come gawk at it under close
supervision because it's like and if we
did was there well and if we didn't have
the ability again because this is the
thing that interestingly you know an
animal an animal other than the human
animal doesn't have the capacity to
attach sentimental value to things to it
to the degree that we do right I mean
obviously you Coco the sign-language
gorillas I'm sure that she in fact I
think she had some possessions that
meant a lot to her I'm not saying yeah
they don't have the capacity but not
nearly the capacity that we do and then
you talk about robots and when are they
gonna become indiscernible from us and
are they gonna have the ability like
that's one of the things we do we're
just constantly attaching value and
we're going to attach value to the
robots because we're gonna tell
ourselves a story about them and once we
have the story straight that robot is
gonna be just as significant as a person
and we're gonna be like this is my best
friend yeah he's a robot but who cares
but as that robot gonna feel the same
way is he gonna have the we're gonna
have to program that robot with the
capacity to tell itself lies and tell
itself stories about things in order to
have to for there to be significance in
its life oh that's the question
that's the question tonight maybe I just
I think it's I think it's undeniably
healthy to have a few real things in
like the real hard world that you can
touch and feel and taste if you need to
in order to maintain a connection with
something meaningful but don't take it
too far and then if you lose it just
move on it'll come back in a box on your
deathbed and shouldn't you throw that it
soon as you have the technology to throw
that wedding ring into a into a 3d
copier should you do it nope because the
one thing that's valuable about it is
that one part that can't be can't be it
can't be conveyed it's that this one
this particular thing was wrapped around
his finger now it's wrapped around my
finger so in a replica of it would be a
replica okay
I mean you buy those that you buy
replicas in the museum gift shop so what
if somebody took me know what if
somebody took one of your children put
them in a person and to get any and put
them in a 3d in a 3d copier and made a
perfect copy of your child everything
was intact memories everything exactly
the same and then they killed the
original child would you what kind of
value would you associate would you say
I can't I can't love this new child even
though it would be like Lando saying
daddy it's just me
Lando I mean thinking about that dogs
man horrifying okay
but it's a legitimate question man okay
Jade Jade and I'm not talking about a
clone because the clone is a separate
being I'm saying legitimately like a
copy like there's some technology that
organizes all the matter in exactly the
same way and then kills the existing
thing and like well I mean what kind of
value would you be like yeah that's Jade
too it's just a
yeah I could I can conduct a
relationship and ultimately for the most
part it would it would be the same
moving forward but it doesn't have the
same shake and it's just a keepsake and
a relationship or just different things
the apples and oranges I think it's just
a you know but you have a relationships
with keepsakes
they represent no you don't it's not a
relationship it's uh that's all about
the story tangible nostalgia I'm gonna
steal your ring and you're gonna think
you lost it and then at the end of your
life I'm gonna give you a box and the
only thing that's gonna be in there is
that wedding ring okay and I'll say you
remember that question that that dude
asked us that one time on your biscuits
that's why I did this it was a big
experiment to teach you a lesson and
then to give you a special present at
the end of your life well listen now
I'll commit to thinking about it some
but let me sleep on it I'm kind of
sleepy at this point I'm resorting to
say an egg can we in this podcast I'm
gonna sleepy and just don't but uh you
know I'll twinkle with my ring and I'll
think about it okay and you know what
you think about it to let us know what
you think will speak at you this time
next week is that a deal
[Music]